ami Tinkler is one of Britain's greatest
ever gymnasts the youngest member of
Team GB she won a bronze medal at the
Rio Olympics there she shared the podium
with America's Simone biles and at the
time seemed overjoyed it's incredible
coming into the games I didn't even
expect a microphone off then to medal in
the fine I was just incredible but three
years later she announced her shock
retirement at the age of just 19 now
she's the highest profile gymnast yet to
allege she was a victim of a culture of
bullying and control British gymnastics
says it is investigating a complaint
made by Tinkler in December last year
and it's at an advanced stage the
gymnast says the experiences I shared
with a reason for my retirement in
January not a physical injury as was
suggested by some at the time after
eight months I'm no closer to having any
feedback or outcome Tinkler's complaints
come after widespread allegations of
abuse in the sport
Eileen Wharton submitted a complaint
about the club where her two daughters
were Lee gymnasts she was told it was
too late as they're now grownups Roxanne
says she was made to train while wearing
a cast she also says she was subjected
to obsessive control of her weight I was
mostly but I wasn't fat by any stretch
the imagination was training uncle
weights so I would know next time that's
how it would feel if I put on weight
Eileen says she has feelings of guilt as
a parent the word I've used is groomed
almost brainwashed into believing that
this is elite sport this is elite
gymnasts because if these kids want to
do well which they did they wanted to
win medals they wanted to be the best
and I was sort of manipulated into
believing that this was necessary for
them to do that Emily Marsden say she
was ostracized from her Club following
complaints made by her mum to British
gymnastics shall with us little little
things that I could easily just improve
like if the hell to me it's just little
things that we just just got to me to
the point where I would cry myself to
sleep sometimes cry and my mom Sky News
is aware of dozens of other parents and
young athletes from clubs around the
country who claimed their complaints
were ignored or dismissed by British
gymnastics an organisation they claimed
became obsessed with medals whatever the
cost
Martha Kellner Sky News